bonjour caroline fiat merci d'être avec
nous cet après midi sur arte france on
le disait vous faites partie de celles
et ceux qui ont repris leur activité
vous est aide soignante
c'était une évidence pour vous de
repartir sur le terrain oui mais fabas
comme tous les soignants personnes se
poserait dans la question quand il ya
une crise sanitaire qui arrive on remet
la blouse et conçoit député conçoit
retraités qu'on soit tout autre chose
voilà on parle beaucoup des députés mais
il faudrait parler d'eux voilà des
retraités qui sont retournés travailler
de ce qui avait changé de métier qui
sont retournés à travailler voilà il
n'ya pas que les députés qui sont
retournés travailler comment vous
accordez justement avec votre avec vos
deux entrées du temps justement j'ai
choisi un travail de nuit comme ça je
travaille la nuit je dors un peu le
matin et l'après midi je gère les
urgences et j'ai une équipe formidable
sandrine grégory et fabien qui prennent
le rôle des députés pendant que je me
repose
alors justement dites nous à quoi
ressemblent vos nuits alors dans quelles
conditions vous travaillez dans quelle
structure vous travaillez actuellement
racontez-nous ce qui se passe vous êtes
en lorraine on le sait une région
particulièrement touchée
alors là c'est un petit peu prématuré
pour que je vous raconte tout ça parce
que comme tout personnel soignant je
suis contrainte ce qui est normal
d'ailleurs au devoir de réserve et de
confidentialité donc tout ça je
raconterai après mais comment vous
comment vous gérez vos journées
racontez-nous sans forcément rentrer
dans dans le détail mais qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous faites à quoi vous
est ce utile aujourd'hui sur le terrain
elle va j'ai fait le travail d'une d'une
aide-soignante comme toute autre aide
soignante je m'occupe des patients dont
j'ai la charge en équipe
pluridisciplinaire et la journée je
m'occupe des commandes et des urgences
parlementaire
je suis aussi un travail de fond d'elle
elle la facilité que j'ai c'est que du
coup j'ai les deux étiquettes donc je
peux alerter sur ce que je peux voir en
tant que soignante en tant que
parlementaire c'est voilà la différence
peut-être par rapport aux autres
on l'a dit vous êtes en lorraine une
région particulièrement touchée par
cette épidémie est ce que vous sentez
que l'hôpital s'organise correctement
dans votre région où il est on est on
est très bien organisée les équipes ont
fait un travail formidable
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que c'est les
soignants qui met tout en place
le chu de nancy par exemple est passée
de 70 lits de réanimation à 160 me il a
fallu déménager des villes et les
réanimateurs il a fallu créer de
nouveaux services
ça a été fait par des équipes qui n'ont
pas compté leurs heures et la fatigue
pour recréer ces services donc tout est
mis en place
côté logistique c'est assez compliqué ça
a été assez compliqué au départ à savoir
par rapport aux ars ou bas vous tout le
monde est au courant que pour monsieur
lannelongue c'était plus important de
gérer le nombre de licenciements que la
gestion des masques ou des surblouse bon
il est parti désormais donc voilà il ya
eu beaucoup de quoi qui met tout ça on
le verra après la crise mais en tous cas
la gestion de crise par les personnels
est vraiment quelque chose de formidable
est ce que cette plongée justement dans
le milieu médical vous permet d'avoir eu
une analyse forcément plus précises sur
la situation des hôpitaux et vous
permettra d'avoir des informations à
remonter quand vous serez de retour dans
l'hémicycle
oui évidemment je vais me servir de mon
expérience pour faire des propositions
concrètes et faire remonter les choses
mais j'utilise aussi ce temps pour voir
aussi les manques qui peut y avoir et
que voilà j'avais pu trop souvenir ça
faisait trois ans que je n'avais pas
travaillé
j'avais un peu l'angoissé d'avoir perdu
on les bases mais non c'est comme le
vélo ça se perd pas et j'ai utilisé
effectivement tout ça mais j'essaie de
discuter avec les collègues pour savoir
quelle est leur ressenti à eux aussi de
ce qu'ils vivent depuis trois ans
exactement
et justement est-ce qu'ils vous font
remonter déjà certaines choses oui non
mais là ils sont dans une période ils
sont ils sont tellement reconnaissants
des repas qu'ils peuvent recevoir des
applaudissements de ses une période où
il ya une vraie reconnaissance envers le
personnel soignant mais il ya une
crainte de se dire voilà il ya des
collègues qui le disent très bien que
dans quelques mois c'est dommage on
redeviendra les soignants qui répondent
de trop tardivement aux toilettes aux
sonnettes pardon merci beaucoup
caroline fiat d'avoir été avec nous cet
après midi je rappelle que vous êtes
aides soignants donc et député de la
france insoumise merci beaucoup